in the 1990s as commander of Colombia's
largest paramilitary group Salvatore
Mancuso was one of the most feared men
in the country
the United self-defense forces of
Colombia was responsible for the deaths
of thousands of people and the forced
displacement of many more
frequently aided by members of the Armed
Forces politicians and land owners as
part of their bitter war against
leftiscarrias
the relationship with the state was so
strong that Mancuso was invited to speak
to Congress in 2004 in an effort to
convince the country of the legitimacy
of his struggle
he received a standing ovation
faced with the siege of the gorillas we
resorted to the right of self-defense to
protect our existence and property the
paramilitaries disbanded in 2006 under a
controversial peace agreement struck
with then president alvarudibe who
himself has long been accused of having
paramilitary ties
two years later as Mancuso and other
leaders started to talk about their
relationship with the state the
government unexpectedly extradited them
to the United States on drug trafficking
charges but after years of detention in
the U.S Mancus has become increasingly
forthcoming and sharing information and
asking for forgiveness
recognizing responsibilities is the
first step to try to mend what is
possible I apologize from the very depth
of my soul and heart I feel ashamed and
regretful Mancus is now trying to be
accepted by Colombia's transitional
peace tribunal which was created by the
2016 peace deal with farc Rebels
to do so Mancuso will have to prove in a
public hearing here in front of his
victims that indeed he was functionally
and materially incorporated into the
Armed Forces and provide new information
about his relationship with generals
politicians and entrepreneurs that
worries many in the country's Elite
the daughter of an indigenous leader
killed by Mancuso for opposing the
construction of a dam says she's still
waiting for the full truth recently
Mancuso said he had been following
direct orders by the state I want to
know the whole truth the details of who
is behind The Disappearance of my father
where are his remains I know I would
find some peace if I knew who is
responsible the complete truth Mancuso's
motivations to talk appear to be
self-serving if allowed to enter into
the transitional justice system he could
avoid future prosecution for other
alleged crimes but whatever the reasons
his victims hope this will finally
reveal the truth behind the Bloodshed
Alessandra Al Jazeera